lives in New York he works on around the
horn he covers a basketball for the
athletic and Frank joins us now good
morning Frank Dan how are you I tend to
lash out at everybody so I'm probably
russell westbrook category all right
before I get to James Dolan the incident
last night what do you make of that
what's the Commissioner do yeah I think
this is an interesting one for him
because you know you had the fight last
night with Serge Ibaka and marquise
Chris but I would think that this is
probably on top of his desk this morning
I think for Russell Westbrook you know
it's like a he said he said we don't
know exactly know what happened what if
I saw Westbrook feels that that's what
this gentleman said I could see why he
would be angry about I think he would
have helped his case a little bit if you
didn't threaten the wife in this in this
one yeah I could see you getting mad and
maybe alerting security to it but you
know it seems like the person who said
something might have a history according
to maybe some of the social media stuff
and then Russell Westbrook has gotten
into it a couple of times
with what's going on in Utah if you
remember he walked up the court last
year at the end of that playoff game
which ended with a bit of controversy
because it looked like Paul George might
have been fouled shooting a three
nothing was called and before you knew
it he was walking you know the series
was over and as Westbrook was walking
off the court someone had a cell phone
cameras kind of sticky in his face he
slapped that the guys had knew so you
know that I think this all kind of goes
into it I just think that Russell in
that case I think if he had to do all
over again it's one thing to get mad at
the at the guy in this case but like you
know to basically be threatening his
wife to I think that's where he didn't
help himself yeah I mentioned this fan
had taken down a social media seat and
checked it a couple minutes ago and it's
back up so I'm not quite sure what it is
but I think we should we should be
vetting out both sides here
understanding what Russell Westbrook
heard but also where's this fan coming
from and judging from social media in
which he says is now fake news he had an
agenda that he there's definitely a
profile here of this guy so before we
you know cast aspersions with Russell
Westbrook I got a look at both sides
yeah but I think the commissioners gonna
have to come down on Russell Westbrook
you know he's gonna have to well come on
yeah we know that this stuff used to go
on all the
time you know interactions between
players and pencils know that Charles
Barkley I'm sure has got into it a bunch
of time same thing even Reggie Miller
it's just that everyone in the crowd
wasn't there with the cellphone camera
recording everything and I think that
probably played into it a little because
I think the fans and I'm you know you
and I we've been to Utah we've been
there for games so the fans here are
tough you know I mean did that Utah
Indiana Detroit they have some really
tough fans weren't afraid to you know
the say things to players and I think in
this case the people sitting near the
bench I think they wanted to get under
Russell Westbrook skin because it had
happened before and there were people
recording it obviously as he kind of
went off on this guy your most recent
article after Jim Dylan's latest
confrontation at Garden Charles Oakley
calls for the Commissioner to step in I
watched around the horn with your
comments about Dolan that basically
don't be so sensitive with something
like this he's heard this before but he
did ban a fan a couple years ago for
basically the same thing what what can
the Commissioner do with the Knicks
situation with this owner well you know
they haven't done anything before and if
you remember the officer he was in here
was like four or five years ago and
right before the also games here there
was a gentleman who sent you know on a
letter kind of expressing you know his
disappointment and how things are being
run and Jim Dolan responded because the
guy was kind of a nasty letter accused
the guy probably being an alcoholic and
the guy's son and that I'm releasing
that letter and when Adam Silver was
asked about it it's kind of guy I want
that system don't kind of be you know a
competitive guy being feisty but has
happened
on a number of occasions and for me
anyway if that's you as you're walking
up the court and somebody says something
to you maybe there's a chance that you
might say something back but I think you
have to put everything in proper
perspective here you know you want the
owner of a franchise that is one one
playoff series since 2001 the team
currently has 13 wins you can't sit
there and tell me just because and I get
it he pays the players he pays his
executives his coaches everybody makes a
lot of money but that's not just what
goes into being a good owner if the fans
only care about the results on the court
and there's there's no arguing the
results on the court they haven't been
good since Jim Dolan has been in charge
there and if once in a while a fans
gonna sell the team I would say this Dan
I'm surprised it doesn't happen more
often at the garden I think the
are incredibly patient we know all about
years ago when they flew the banner over
Giants Stadium about selling the team it
happens all the time in Europe with the
soccer team and they think the manager
isn't any good or the owner somebody
will rent a plane and they'll fly
they'll have like some kind of sign
flying over the stadium oh I guess
luckily for Madison Square Garden it
doesn't have a see through it doesn't
have to look at stuff like that well I'm
also wondering this in the offseason
Frank where if if they luck into Zion
Williamson you're not gonna luck into
Kevin Durant and/or Kyrie Irving but why
would they want to go into this
situation you know everybody wants to be
a savior and you know I can be a good
guy going to the Knicks and we make the
Knicks relevant here but I'm just
wondering as a free agent you know why
would I want not that it matters I guess
who the owner is but in this situation
it feels like it does well it does in a
lot of ways because I think if you look
at a lot of you know players but it
definitely coaches and executives who
have gotten a you can't tell me that
being in New York enhance their legacy
whether or not was Larry Brown Phil
Jackson Isiah Thomas Carmelo Anthony
Amar'e Stoudemire Jason Kidd you know
kind of the list goes on another one guy
who I think got out of it pretty good
was probably Jeremy Lin when he was
saying that was only a short time what
would concern me for guys like Kevin
Durant and Kyrie urban I think you hit
on it coming to New York that could be
part of it and think about what I could
do for my legacy if I win I also think a
lot of it could be about stuff off the
court kind of like what LeBron has going
on in LA and I think sometimes for these
guys that they make moves that really
aren't based on basketball first and
foremost and really if Kevin Durant
wouldn't leave to go and say where is
he's in one of the greatest situations
you'll be in for an NBA player you know
in the next maybe 50 years that's a
ideal place the Celtics are the Celtics
have a history they got young players
and all this talent you know if you go
to the Knicks you're taking a risk but
you also wonder is there extra
motivation and sometimes that could
backfire I think LeBron every move that
he's made in his career to me was about
basketball the one to the Lakers was
basketball family and obviously the the
business part of it in that and the
basketball is back part I don't think
there's any question about it yeah be
interesting offseason I'm curious the
best team in the east
the
the team that will come out of the East
this years whoo yeah I still tend to go
with Toronto just because I would love
to see it be Milwaukee but that group of
players you know that team hasn't won a
playoff series yet now you're asking
them to go pretty far I mean Kawhi
Leonard is the most accomplished
postseason player but I guess with the
exception of Dwyane Wade in the Eastern
Conference he's been to the finalists
twice he's been a Finals MVP and a lot
of the players on that team had been
through the playoffs before they've won
playoff series he's kind of like the
difference maker that they haven't had
so essentially what Toronto did was they
traded them are DeRozan they moved
LeBron James to a different conference
and they had a Kawhi Leonard it was a
win-win all the way around I still tend
to go with them just because of the fact
that Kawhi Leonard's done it before good
too busy with you Frank thanks as always
we appreciate your time good Dan thanks
a lot anytime that's Frank Isola the
athletic and around the horn contributor
as well for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]